money does offer this really cool thing
which is uh I won't experience in my
life like I want to know what it's like
to completely check out from uh to use
the manosphere term if you will the the
the the the Matrix like I want to know
what it's like to do everything in my
life because I want to do it not because
I have to and
um you know maybe I'm not sorry from the
Matrix is what you're talking exactly
yeah so it's like the red pill Andrew uh
listen I'm doing it but I believe it's
like so rare because I don't think it's
like very natural to do that as a human
so I'm curious like and I don't know how
much money you got I think I know you
got some money I'm borrowing money from
you
but like but like when you get to the
point where you don't have to work right
yeah weird thing happens
you have to find something that you want
it what I've always done is like I've
I've gone I'm gonna do what I love and
find a way to make money at it because I
don't want to do something I don't love
because that's going to drive me crazy
but if I love something then I can put
everything in it and I can just give it
my all